je vous le disais ce sont maintenant
quatre personnes qui sont recherchées
elle serait à l'origine du règlement de
comptes qui a coûté la vie à l'enfant
par ailleurs plusieurs associations et
des responsables de gauche ont critiqué
les méthodes de nicolas sarkozy le fait
par exemple que l'opération de police
menée aujourd'hui était annoncé à l'as
vence
et puis le vocabulaire du ministre de
l'intérieur est également dénoncée il
avait affirmé vouloir nettoyer le
quartier zine dine boudaoud sébastien
lafargue le ministre l'avait promis la
police l'a fait à la mi journée les
forces de l'ordre prennent possession de
la cité où le petit sidi ahmed a été tué
200 hommes parmi lesquels ceux du raid
le groupe d'intervention de la police
ce déploiement annoncé la veille n'a pas
surpris la population de ce quartier de
la courneuve
les petits sont plutôt curieux les
grands partagés quant à l'efficacité de
cette opération
c'est normal quand même que la police
elle fasse ce travail parce que tirer
sur un enfant même si c'est ce même si
ça paqueter voulu moi je trouve ça
inadmissible
s'ils veulent régler leurs comptes qui
leurs règles ailleurs mais pas coach a
des enfants c'est tout comme sa poésie
derrière le ménage les policiers ont
tenté de le faire pendant deux heures
ils n'ont rien laissé au hasard
les caves les sous sols les cages
d'escalier mais ils n'ont rien trouvé
ou presque et surtout aucune trace des
quatre jeunes recherché après la mort de
six diamètre
plus que la méthode de nicolas sarkozy
ce sont ces propos qui ont choqué ses
adversaires politiques
hier il affirmé qu'il allait nettoyer
les quartiers jeu sarkozy utilise un
langage violent expéditif qui montre en
quelque sorte un aveu de faiblesse
cet après midi le ministre de
l'intérieur n'a rien retiré à ses propos
ce v6 en a qui sont choqués par le cames
nettoyage moi ce qui me choque c'est
qu'on puisse que l'utilisation de rauzan
quand je vois des bandes 1 qui trafic de
la drogue dans les halls d'immeubles
il faut me trouviez
quand je vois des voyous avaient des
fusils à pompe ou détruire ni voyous ni
trafiquants à la courneuve aujourd'hui
les policiers sont repartis bredouilles
mais dans leur esprit ce n'est que
partie remise
justice avec